Prime Minister Teresa May says the
London attack represents a new trend
she believed terrorists are starting to
copy each other may also says that
technology companies need to stop
terrorists from working together online
we cannot allow this ideology the safe
space it needs to breed yet that is
precisely what the internet and the big
companies that provide internet-based
services provide we need to work with
allied democratic governments to reach
international agreements that regulate
cyberspace to prevent the spread of
extremists and terrorism planning CBS
News senior national security analyst
Brand Townsend and with us she was
president george w bush's homeland
security adviser she has been
interviewed by trump administration
officials seeking a new FBI director
friend good morning good morning how
significant is this component this
cyberspace component and how should it
be addressed Charlie I think that this
is the single most important component
right now let's remember and using the
telegram channel the encrypted messaging
application Isis called for Ramadan
attacks using cars knives and guns and
we've seen this incredible rise in these
Ramadan attacks right now and so I think
what Theresa May is trying to say is we
need to battle the cyber space just as
you would the physical space air seal
and we need to approach it in that way
as a to confront them to deny them the
use of the Internet President Trump very
busy over the weekend on Twitter about
calling for the travel ban and then
again this morning renewed calls for the
travel ban is there any indication to
your evidence that the travel ban would
make a difference in these kind of
attacks you know it's it's interesting
look Gail we've got there are there is a
threat from those entering the country
with intentions to do his harm I think
that's what he's talking about in this
case in the London case the police chief
came out this morning and said he thinks
what they are dealing with at least in
this most recent case is a largely
domestic threat and of course the travel
ban doesn't address that which is why
you've got to address the cyber space in
order to address the domestic the self
radicalized individual addressing the
cyberspace issue you know I read this
morning that Twitter said its suspended
370,000 accounts in the second half of
2017 for promoting terrorism that's a
huge number it sounds like they're
trying to do something they are they
were very late to the game and they had
to be sort of shamed into doing it and
they have an understandable and
righteous concern about First Amendment
I get that by the same token you can't
allow yourselves to provide the social
media company's material support right
this is it would be that's a criminal
offense to provide material support and
so you have to do more they have to
deploy technology that will allow them
to identify video audio pictures and
take them down north their videos still
online right now there are Gail and
Anwar al-aulaqi is probably the best
example an american-born al-qaeda cleric
who was rightly and legally targeted
with a drone attack by President Obama
and killed if you go online right now
and you google him you can bring up his
sermons and so he's that stuff still
online and he's permitted to terrorize
us from the grave and President Obama
used to say that this is a decades-long
struggle some other people have said
this is the new normal as hard as it is
to say that is that what we're facing
well look surely when somebody can pick
up a household item knife or take his
car and decide he's going to use that as
a form of inflicting terror I think
that's why Theresa May is talking about
we've got to you know we have this
campaign here if you see something say
something you've got to get into these
communities you have to have Imams and
community leaders help you to identify
this because if you're waiting to
disrupt this when the person picks up
the knife you're going to lose and so
you really have to get into these
communities and have them feel that they
have a stake in disrupting terrorist
that's intelligence that's right third
attack in Britain in three months why
are there target or seem to be a target
at this time they do although I'll tell
you Gail I do think that the French feel
this the Belgians and Brussels right
this is a Western European problem where
they have these communities that feel
sort of alienated they don't you know in
this country when you come to America we
integrate you and you feel like you've
got a stake in it and I think that
Europe is feeling the pressure to do a
better job there Fran Townsend always
good to have your expertise thank you
thank you